donc est donc valable comme il l'a fait
je sais plus quel tri pascal pascal le
grand frère joué au quiz première fois
je vais vous donner où ça s'est passé
pour tous ceux qui sont autour de la
table et vous allez s'est trouvé entre
vous dans la garçonnière de mon père
sous l'eau dans une piscine qui a fait
sa première fois sous dos ou dans une
piscine
ce qui a fait ça dans le lit d'un homme
plus âgé qui a fait ça en colonie de
vacances
d'ailleurs colonies je crois qu'il ya
quinzaine mairie si on pouvait éviter
les fautes d'orthographe
parce que je vous le dis j'ai encore
acheté le concours tout à l'heure c'est
bon dans sa chambre merci à ils vont le
faire car les cinq mois
alors
dans un champ et à la fête du collège
alors moi j'ai surtout envie de savoir
qu'il a fait la fête du collège parce
que
j'ai moi qui sait la rue que je
m'attendais pas à ça alors à votre avis
qui a fait ça dans la garçonnière
on va dans la garçonnière de son père
tout simplement gilbert se dit gilles
verdez gênant ce nom c'est pas vous dans
belle isabelle non non non dit raymond
roux thierry moreau non non non il
n'aura non c'est pas une aura non plus
oui mais moi c'est christophe carrière
savais tu que le problème du dépucelage
c'est qu'il faut trouver l'endroit
maintenant on est on est jeune voilà bah
il faut aller chez nous tout va les
voiles affalées je trouve l'endroit et
et mon père qui était assez chaud ça va
durer longtemps
votre père qui est assez chaude après
wau me demandais je voudrais pas très
bien merci en tout cas c'était celle ci
suit avec dans l'est est génial et après
tu es t elle sa copine et moi il m'a
proposé
ouais c'était rien à faire avec des ados
sous l'eau dans une piscine qui a fait
ça sous l'eau dans une piscine
commandant cousteau
comment booster nord kivu monovalent
nabil arabi la wii c'est la bidc vous
n'avez la soul au dos mais si tu sais
pas mais j'ai des bahamas où le bain
c'était lui qui est sous l'eau ma tête a
été pas sous l'eau ah ouais c'est sûr
vous vous êtes nabila où loana parce que
à bidart et donc alors racontez nous
comment s'est passé je me rappelle plus
trop elle a coincé dans une quoi mais
c'était il ya longtemps par tous les
temps s'il vous plaît et c'était bon sa
maîtresse bat ya longtemps c'est quoi la
joie n'a pas trop longtemps genre mais
vous avez quel âge vous déjà 21 puisqu'à
chaque fois ils songent d'agen chaque
jour hier à laver 21 aujourd'hui à la 22
d'aumale va avoir 40 et on ne peut le
poser une question est ce que c'est une
piscine municipale le stand piscine à
vagues mais c'est une piscine d'un club
med sinon c est ce qu avait pas de vague
au début et qui en a eu à la fin non
alors et donc c'est équivalent sg c'est
plus un français à l'étranger 1,1 à quoi
un français apparemment lui a pas parlé
on n'avait pas marqué cela est alors à
français quoi il était dans le club
depuis longtemps été dans l'eau alors
mais alors j'aurai genre y'a que des
français dans l'eau l arrivée de la
filière française sont prêts à tous les
espagnols vous sortez les allemands si
je les français et alors et donc et donc
voila quoi comme il s'appelait belge et
s'est vu alors qu'arrive ascal pascal le
grand frère
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas demandé pourquoi dans une
piscine mais parce que j'étais au club
med en faire à la corde et de le faire
dans la piscine j'ai reçu une note
d'information sera fait prochainement la
dernière fois avec votre femme dans la
piscine non je n'ai vu se faire virer
par axa dans le lit moi j'ai vu un mec
qu'a fait sentir alors qu'il a eus mais
ils ont viré manu l'état et donc et
lester b et après vous êtes resté avec
lui ou l'aï plus jamais revu
ben si je les revues après s'être acheté
comme à confesse j'étais en vacances
avec ma mère weight accord il ya donc
que c'était au club mais gioria des
activités où on est ensemble alors la
[Musique]
bulle actuelle à sa table allez ola olé
mao les mages ou appel que à 15 heures
il y aura bien sûr concours de tir à
l'arc et bien sûr à 17 heures qui mène à
la piscine
[Applaudissements]
en ce moment ils sont en train
d'investir promettre une image très vite
c'est génial c'est une des activités
hors concours de tir à l'arc en génie
que dans la piscine alors qui a fait ça
dans le lit d'un homme plus âgé alors
déjà la phrase je la comprends pas il ya
délit danone dans le lit d'un homme plus
âgé qui n'aura et laura et vous croyez
qu'elle n'aura été que le captain igloo
et non c'est pas verdès dans le lit d'un
homme plus âgé un visa heather abel et
isabelle c'est possible si vous
connaissent bien ils se connaissent bien
cerceau alors et pour bros wii elle
allait rester dans le reportage à lui
alors qu en pense il est passé à côté de
passer le bac et gt et pour fêter ça à
l'éolien est fermement axée peur je me
suis dit fais taire une femme donc j'ai
choisi un homme qui hakim apporter son
expérience je me suis dit comme je veux
apporter ma jeunesse qui va être très
doit donc vous vous avez également bon
bah comme j'ai passé le bac avec deux
ans de retard j'en avais bien 18 banon
vous allez rentrer à nantes 19 mars et
19 le staff et hull avec l'âge et lui en
avait 46 web et s'il est si l'on regarde
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et on a envie de bien
chapeau l'artiste alors les gens qu il a
été super doux à oui bah oui quand on a
40 ans je ne mets toi c'est exceptionnel
je peux le temps parce que j'ai bossé
très vite
ouais après il m'a fait une halte aux
amandes et du café au lait une truite
aux amandes à c'était georges pernoud
thalassa le gaia sortie il a sorti une
truite vous regardez ce que je te ramène
pas gêner le mektoub du avec la suite ça
va faire une très tôt a renchéri
ambiance libye sans sa salle de bain
qu'est-ce que j'ai ramené